- I accidentally became a
meme and this is that story.
Hi, my name is Michael McGee
and you may know me from this meme
- Hi, I'm Amber.
I am the girl in the
background of the meme.
- I'm Mathew Rosero.
And I'm the guy who took the picture.
- [Michael] This all started in 2013.
Me and my best friend Mathew,
we've known each other since fourth grade.
- Everybody knew who they were.
They were really funny, but
I hadn't ever like talked
to them until our algebra class.
It was my junior year,
their sophomore year.
And I sat by them.
And then we just became
friends after that.
- I don't think we had
any assigned seating.
I can't really remember how we ended
up sitting next to each other,
but we just did for the whole year.
- Michael said he sat by me
because he had a crush on me.
- Yeah. I mean, she she's a cute girl.
So I definitely, at one
point was crushing on her.
It was in October of 2013.
- It was a pretty normal day.
And algebra two, I mean,
the booty had me like
trend was going around
Twitter at the time.
So it was like during that week.
So I'm like scheming up a
plan to try to be like, yo
we got to get into the hashtag.
We got to see who makes the money.
I want to say maybe six
or seventh grade is when
we all kind of noticed that Michael
like every time he would laugh
or make some type of strain that his veins
would pop me knowing Michael
can make his veins bulge out.
I'm like, yo, Michael made
your veins bulge out real quick
and let me take a picture.
And he's like, all right, cool.
- I had to hold my breath and
you know, I just flex my neck
and the head, if that makes sense.
So really, you know, because
the veins are getting cut off
of their oxygen and
blood and they kind of,
you know, bulge out more.
You're also, you're kind of
killing brain cells with it.
Cause you're cutting off the
oxygen flow to your brain.
So it's not the smartest thing to do.
We took it at 12:04
- And I saw him like making the face.
And I was like, what?
What is he doing?
- Then I just snuck my phone,
posted a picture and then
I just left it alone.
I went back to what I was doing.
And then all we just see
throughout the day I get a
couple likes, a couple retweets.
- It was funny, everyone
in the class like saw it
and they all laughed.
- But it was nothing.
As to what happened two months later
- We're on Christmas break in December.
And I went to sleep one night
you know my phone on the charger.
And I woke up and my phone
was really scorching hot.
So I thought like my power outlet
like short circuited or something.
And then I look on my phone and it has
like the 20 plus notification
on your Twitter icon.
And I saw that a guy on Reddit
or a redditor had taken Matthew's tweet
and like kind of pick
stitched it to their own.
And it was when you're holding
in a fart next to your
crush and it just blew up.
Like I had all these people tagging me
in the photo like, Hey, is this you?
I had people like, yo, I
can't believe this is you.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Overnight, I went from
like 700 Twitter followers
to like 3000 or something like that.
It's definitely been a
universal meme, you know
it can be brought into any topic.
- That's I guess the beauty of the picture
you can take it any way you want.
That's what really kept it going
- It was funny to me to
like read all the comments
on like Reddit and Imager and all that.
Like they were quite a few
that like, I'll never forget
- When you're vegan and haven't
told anyone in five minutes
or when you've coughed three
times and you're trying to hold
in another one because
he didn't want people to
think you have COVID.
Personally me, I might be biased
but I think it's a top
five meme of all time.
Again That's just my opinion though.
I definitely wish I would
have taken it more seriously.
Copyrighted, maybe get a legal
team behind me, but you know
some new light with the
NFT community blooming.
I noticed that a lot of the
other meme people that were
in these videos actually
minted and sold their memes
as NFTs, the overly
attached girlfriend Laina.
She went to Northwest high school.
We were in the same track.
We had the same teacher,
you know, I'm going to try
and be like them and get on
the foundation app and you know
mint and publish the original
meme photo, get some money.
And as far with Amber, me
me and Amber were always just really cool.
- We still hang out to this day
Michael and I have made jokes like before
like that we are going to get married
and have it be like a meme wedding.
And like, everybody that was
a meme was going to be invited
but we're just friends.
And like, they'll say whatever
they want on the internet.
- I guess the beauty of the picture
you can like take it any way you want.
And this pictures probably
going to live forever.
So there won't be a moment in your life.
You will not see his face.